CONGRESSMAN DUNCAN HUNTER,
ATTORNEY GENERAL PAM BONDI AND
MORE.
BUT FIRST MY OPENING STATEMENT.
THE RISE OF SOCIALISM HAS NEVER
BEEN MORE CLEAR.
RIGHT NOW IN AMERICA THERE ARE
FORCES DUG IN, ORGANIZED AND
WELL FUNDED, DOING WHATEVER IS
TODAY'S DEMONSTRATIONS ARE PART
ITS VERY CORE.
THEY DEMAND THE ABOLITION OF
I.C.E., IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT, AND THE ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICY OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> WE NEED TO ABOLISH I.C.E.
THEY HAVE STRAYED FROM THE
INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND HUMANITY.
JUDGE JEANINE: ARE YOU STUPID?
I KNOW AS AN ACTRESS YOU ARE
USED TO SAYING WHAT IS ON THE
SCRIPT AND THIS GOVERNMENT THING
IS NEW TO YOU.
BUT STRAYED SO FAR FROM THE
INTERESTS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
THE WHOLE POINT OF I.C.E. IS TO
PROTECT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM
ILLEGALS WHO WOULD DO US HARM
PHYSICALLY AND FINANCIALLY.
LISTEN TO THIS ONE.
>> I.C.E. ISN'T DOING WAY IT'S
CREATED TO DO.
IT'S BEING USED AS HIS OWN
DOING WHAT IT WAS CREATED TO DO?
I.C.E. IS DOING EXACTLY WHAT IT
POLICE FORCE?
AND YOU THINK I.C.E. IS MAKING
US LESS SAFE?
I HAVE GOT TWO WORD FOR YOU.
FOR ALL YOU GENIUSES OUT THERE.
I.C.E. DOES NOT SEPARATE PARENTS
AND CHILDREN AT THE BORDER.
BORDER PATROL DOES THAT.
NARCOTICS AND 90% OF THE HEROIN.
PRAY TELL, WHO DEPORTS THE
SHOULD WE JUST LET BY GONES BE
AND GIVE HIS HIS FOOD STAMPS AND
CALL IT A DAY?
YOU DON'T WANT THEM DEPORTED.
NEIGHBOR THEY SHOULD COME LIVE
WITH YOU.
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND WHO HAS
AMBITIONS TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT
IN 2020 SAYS --
>> WE SHOULD PROTECT FAMILIES
TODAY.
WE SHOULD GET RID OF IT, START
OVER AND REIMAGINE IT WITH
SOMETHING THAT WORKS.
JUDGE JEANINE: WHENEVER A
DEMOCRAT DOESN'T WANT TO FOLLOW
THE LAW, THEY SAY IT'S BROKEN.
I SAY THE TAX SYSTEM IS BROKEN
AND WE DON'T HAVE TO PAY OUR
TAXES AND WE CAN SUCK ANOTHER
COUNTRY DRY.
THAT WAY NONE OF US HAVE TO PAY
TAXES.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT THE
IMMIGRATION LAWS EVEN FORCED.
THE MORE WHO COME IN, THE MORE
TAXES WE PAY FOR EDUCATION, AND
SOCIAL SERVICES.
NONE OF THIS IS FAIR TO THOSE
IMMIGRANTS WHO PLAYED BY THE
RULES.
THE NARRATIVE OF TODAY'S PROTEST
IS BACKWARDS.
THOSE MARCHING OBJECT TO ADULTS
WHO CROSS THE BORDER BEING
SEPARATED FROM THEIR CHILDREN.
IT HAPPENED EVEN BEFORE TRUMP
WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT.
NO ONE CARED OR PROTESTED.
TRUMP ENDED THE FAMILY
SEPARATION, YET THEY STILL
THE OVERARCHING MESSAGE IS
ILLEGALS, PEOPLE WHO DO NOT
RESPECT OUR LAWS ARE ENTITLED TO
EVERYTHING WE AMERICANS ARE.
WEALTH, OUR CAPITALISTIC SUCCESS
AND WAY OF LIFE WITH THEM.
THIS, MY FRIENDS, IS SOCIALISM.
LIKE THE WOMEN'S MARCH, THESE
ANTI-TRUMP PROTESTERS ARE
EXTREMELY WELL ORGANIZED.
THEY ARE MORE THAN POLITICAL.
THEY ARE IDEOLOGICAL.
WE ARE WITNESSING THE EVOLUTION
OF A SOCIALIST COUP.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE WHAT I AM
SAYING LISTEN TO IT FROM THEIR
OWN MOUTHS.
28-YEAR-OLD CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATE WHO TOOK DOWN A
LONG-TERM CONGRESSMAN.
FOR WORKING HARD, SHE WON THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA.
A LITTLE KNOWN SOCIALIST FROM
VERMONT WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
CANDIDATE IN 2016 BUT FOR THE
CORRUPTION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
SOCIALISTS ARE BEGINNING TO WIN
ELECTIONS AT THE STATE AND
NATIONAL LEVEL, DEFEATING EVEN
LONG-TERM INCUMBENTS.
EXPECT MORE HARD LEFT CANDIDATES
TO RUN.
EVEN OBAMA'S "LIFE OF JULIA"
SUGGESTS AN ANTI-CAPITALIST
FRAMEWORK.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO NEED
REMINDING, SOCIAL I. DOESN'T
WORK.
ACCORDING TO THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL," PEOPLE GO THROUGH
GARBAGE BAGS TO TAKE WHATEVER
THEY CAN THEN TRY TO SELL THE
EMPTY BAGS IN VENEZUELA.
INCOME IS SUBJECT TO STATE
CONTROL AND IT HASN'T WORKED OUT
WELL IN SWEDEN EITHER.
PREGNANT MOTHERS ARE TURNED AWAY
FROM MA TURNITY WARDS BECAUSE OF
OVER -- MATERNITY WARDS, CAUSING
PREGNANT WOMEN TO GIVE BIRTH ON
THE STREETS.
PAY PAY TAXES, BELIEVE IN
CAPITALISM AND HAVE NO PLANS TO